[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute gibt ein richtig richtig leckeres
rezept ich glaube es gab eigentlich das
was uns noch nie so richtig geschmeckt
hat aber egal heute gibt's was und zwar
türkische sesamkringel szene kennt ihr
vielleicht entweder von eurem türkei
besucht oder von der türkischen bäckerei
und die sind wahnsinnig länger die könnt
ihr zu bereiten wenn ihr frühstückt oder
auch mal mittags zum tee oder kaffee
oder auch einfach so weise lecker sind
somit ist so eine abwandlung oder
einfach eine andere version von den
amerikanischen weg uns das heißt der
meere da gibt es einfach bagels in der
türkei gibt es mit in deutschland gibt
es brötchen und somit wird nahezu allem
gegessen es gibt eine unterschied und
zwar einmal geht sie etwas weich und
richtig fluffig ist das mache ich heute
und dann gibt es noch ein knuspriges
image und ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz
den hefeteig dem könnt ihr auch ganz
gerne wenn ihr zum beispiel sonntags
morgens damit frühstücken wollt könnt
ihr den samstagabend schon zu bereiten
und einfach im kühlschrank aufgehen
lassen und dann habt ihr am nächsten
morgen teig und hitze mit zubereiten
habe ich schon gemacht ich zeige euch
mal den teig einen würfel hefe 200 gramm
wasser einen esslöffel zucker 250
milliliter milch 200 gramm
sonnenblumenöl 800 gramm mehl da habe
ich jetzt im 550er weizenmehl ihr könnt
aber auch 630 der dinkel nehmen und zwei
teelöffel salz wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr ganz gerne dann falls ihr den tag
über nacht gehen lasst die hefe menge
reduzieren also um die hälfte müsst ihr
aber auch gar nicht also ich hatte das
auch schon mit einem ganzen würfel
gemacht und hat auch gut geschmeckt
auch sehr gut
jedenfalls gibt jetzt schon mal hefe
wasser und zucker in eine rührschüssel
und könnt das ganze entweder mit der
hand vernähten oder auch mit der
küchenmaschine
jetzt kurz verrühren
man gibt jetzt schon mal einen teil mail
dazu
dann kann ich da nämlich die restlichen
zutaten dazugeben und das restliche mehl
gebe ich dann gleich dazu während der
teig verknetet wird so kann man alles
ganz gut einarbeiten
salz auch immer nicht so wenig verwenden
weil es uns verteilt einfach nicht so
gut schmeckt das öl teppich auch gleich
mal mit rein und dieses limit art die
ich heute zu bereit die nennt sie jene
türkei putschte fans die mit kabarett
mit suchtmitteln sehen wir alles was so
ganz luftig und lustig ist und deswegen
ist es so süß und dann gibt's noch ein
unterschied zwischen so taxi miete also
straßen zimt und
optimiert also haushalts mit weil ich
glaube die frauen in den hausfrauen dazu
dass die das hinbekommt irgendwie keine
ahnung es gibt so taxi mit der bilanz
damit also haushalts mit und dann gibts
sogar noch bastian ist er mit dem also
becker reiste mit ja wir machen heute
passt dann ist er mit der becker reiste
mit zu hause das kriegt die auch zu
hause
hier schonmal verrühren und ich kann
hier bei der kern wird immer ganz gut
schon mal hitze mit drauf geben so 34
grad dann wird der hefeteig schon mal
warm und da geht später einfach viel
viel schneller auf weil er eben schon
diese werbe hat
[Musik]
und er knetet ihr den teig für etwa zehn
minuten wieder schön geschmeidig ist und
je nach milchsorte kann immer sein dass
ihr so ein bisschen mehr oder ein
bisschen weniger milde braucht aber der
teig sollte einfach nicht zu fest sein
schön weich und gleichzeitig schreiben
der teig hat jetzt eine richtig schöne
konsistenz also er sieht ein bisschen zu
weich auf er ist aber nicht so war ich
der darf echt nicht so fest und klumpig
sein denn im prinzip ist es so je mehr
flüssigkeit da jetzt drin ist und eben
im teig gebunden werden kann um so
luftig und flüssiger wird eben das obst
gebäck so ein bisschen wie nehme ich
jetzt hier
da ist das schöne stück
schön zu einer kugel formen
einfach so von außen nach innen
geschlagen und dann habt ihr nämlich
eine schöne oberfläche könnte ihnen dann
umdrehen und dann sofort und dann werde
ich ihn einfach in die schüssel
zurücklegen mit etwas back trends gray
auch bestreuen er ist grün und ihn dann
einfach aufgehen lassen das dauert
entweder bei raumtemperatur eine stunde
oder wie gesagt über nacht und
kühlschrank oder im ofen bei der stufe
30 minuten oder in der kennwort ihr seht
es gibt viele möglichkeiten hefeteig
aufgehen zu lassen oder in der kämmerei
für ungefähr 30 45 minuten oder unter
einer wahren bettdecke macht das gerne
wie ihr möchtet jedenfalls lassen wir
ihn jetzt eine schöne fahrt
[Musik]
jetzt ist der hefeteig wundervoll
aufgegangen man sieht schon der ist
richtig richtig schön und für die
fertigstellung brachte jetzt noch
eigentlich nur noch zwei zutaten nämlich
trauben melasse und sesam sesam könnte
jetzt gerne entweder den ungeschälten
oder geschälten neben der ungeschälte
hat so ein bisschen ein stärkeres aroma
der geschälte ist ein bisschen milder
und feiner also falls ist nicht ganz so
stark mitnehmen über den geschälten oder
es gibt sogar noch schwarzem sesam man
könnte auch beides mission wenn ihr
möchtet als ich habe ich sesam und dann
habe ich hier eben wie gesagt diese
trauben melasse und melasse ist wirklich
ein ganz ganz gesundes lebensmittel das
ist nämlich kein trauben sirup also
nicht mit zucker angereichert sondern es
werden einfach die trauben eingekocht
und es ist sehr eisenhaltig und in der
türkei ist es auch so dass man
eigentlich egal was man hat sagt man
immer hier ein löffelchen pack mers so
heißt das ganze pack mas wir lassen und
dann gibt man das eben schwangeren oder
kindern oder kranken menschen weil es
einfach sehr gesundheitliche ja
eigenschaften hat gesundheitlich
positive eigenschaften und deswegen
macht nur dass eben ganz gerne und jetzt
nehmt ihr euch einfach
einen tiefen teller und gebt da die
melasse rein und ein bisschen warmes
wasser dass wir damit sozusagen verdünnt
dann stelle ich das kurz zur seite und
nehmen noch den anderen teller da kommt
jetzt langsam rein
[Musik]
da
gequetschten kriegsschiffe drängt ok
jetzt nehmt ihr euch den teig heraus
und teilt ihn am besten zehn
gleichmäßige portionen 1
ich glaube ich nehme dafür meinen torten
einteiler
[Musik]
und dann formt die jetzt erst mal
einzeln zu kugeln
einfach da irgendwie besser arbeiten
kann
nein ich mach kein quatsch
das nehmt ihr euch eine kugel davon und
halbiert sie
und dann folgt ihr daraus zwei stränge
sie sollten möglichst gleichmäßig sein
ihr seht auch das sonntag bei dem man
echt gar keinen mehr braucht wenn man
hier auf der silikon mutter arbeitet
oder auch auf einer arbeitsplatte
da ist nämlich echt schön elastisch und
klebt eben nicht und dann dreht er jetzt
diese zwei um einander
verheiratet
[Musik]
und dann zu einem schönen kringel
mit da hat man halt irgendwann dann
schon so
ich dachte immer man kann das irgendwie
machen dass man so gar kein übergang
sieht aber muss es halt so ein bisschen
verknoten und dann ist der kreml
eigentlich erst mal fertig schlägt ihm
kurz zur seite und wird es jetzt hier
mit all machen und dann geht es gleich
weiter mit dem eintippen
und es auch was das kann man echt schön
auch mit kindern machen und dieses image
die werden schon recht groß also so wie
man sie auch in der türkei kennt aber
wenn ich gesagt wo hat es uns echt so
groß dann macht einfach die kleinere
portion aber ich finde das passt schon
ganz gut da kann man mal was rein legen
oder eben das ganze tippen ich finde die
schöne grüße
[Musik]
ok jetzt
habe ich die kringel fertig und jetzt
kommt eben die
sesam und melasse tätigkeit und zwar und
da ist es eigentlich immer besser man
macht es zu zweit denn es ist schon so
wie beim panel also beim panieren es ist
so dass man halt oft wenn man zum
beispiel fleisch oder gemüse paniert
dann tor und ist auch erst in mehl dann
in ein und dann zum beispiel in seiner
größe und irgendwann hat man selber so
panierte finger außer man macht es dann
so dass man eine hand ist dann so in der
nassen flüssigkeiten einer hand bleibt
trocken bei den kriegen geht es nicht
ganz so gut weil die einfach recht groß
und unhandlich sind deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht nämlich jetzt die mutter dazu
demnach dass derzeit viel mehr spaß
natürlich mache oder machst du ach komm
mach du die melasse hat dann tauschen
dann machen wir es doch so und zwar
einmal dann in die melasse tauchen von
beiden seiten nötig dann so von der
seite so ein bisschen ja also mit dem
finger oder mit löffel genau aber ich
finde so ganz gut einfach komplett
benetzen
und dann legt die utah mir ist hier rein
und ich hab es ein bisschen einfacher
ich kann dann hier bisschen schütteln
und dann habe ich den schönen hefe
kringel und kann ihn aufs blech legen
[Musik]
uta rasche die schon mal gegessen kenne
ich nicht noch kein zement geld noch
nicht im moment wird türkei aber dubai
schon in der tasche
wo genau sie die
urlaubsregion ja klar
jetzt damit gehen wir zusammen die
türkei ja das wäre natürlich toll dass
ich natürlich was ganz anderes hotel ja
und dann gibt es da wird es ziemlich
ganz typisch balgheimer honig mit mit
waben und karl marx diesen namen ja
ja das problem und später auch dann
machen wir uns nämlich eine schöne
themen schwarze und den
apotheker so typisch türkisch wobei ich
sagen muss der abschnitt den die dann
oft serviert haben das war halt schon
immer ein sehr süßes und instant aber
das gehört hat wenig so zum türkeiurlaub
stationen jaja den gab es bei uns im
hotel süße apfeltee und dann wurde er
unter jungs damals die varianz kleiner
so gut geschmeckt dass man mit nach
hause immerhin ja und dann zu hause
gemacht gut gehabt
und dann weiter dass der türkische staat
oder auch wichtig
die macher den
medien oft halt im urlaub schmeckt alles
besser da ist das klima an der stimme
hatte urlaub schöner und animationen
reise dazu den pamukkale zudem lokale
karas an die hand das war schon wichtig
sagt
das machen wir mal eine rundreise mit
der jva nie wollten wir einmal mitnahme
müssen wir mal gucken das ja eine schöne
reise machen
ja wir machen jetzt hier noch fertig und
dann werde ich schon mal das erste blech
in kalten backofen stellen und so können
wir das morgen zu machen also wirklich
schönen samstagabend teig zubereiten und
dann morgens kurz dieses image formen
und dann im kalten ofen stellen auf
ungefähr 190 grad das erste blech
braucht sondern auch um ungefähr
da sage ich mal so 20 30 35 minuten bis
da eben auch hoch heißt und die weiteren
fläche könnt ihr bis dahin abdecken oder
ihr packt das ganze bei heißluft dann
können wir auch zwei bücher gleichzeitig
packen und ja das ganze dann eben
parallel machen
also jetzt schönen ofen und was ich
schon als tipp noch geben kann falls er
eine dampfen besitzt könnt ihr auch
gerne dampf stufe eins dazu geben
ansonsten backen sie auch ohne dampf
hervorragend
[Musik]
meine sesamkringel dieses limit sind
fertig gebacken und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach kurz wie wir ein türkisches
frühstück herrichten ich habe jetzt auch
schon t aufgesetzt bei uns gibt zwar
immer traditionell den türkischen
schwarztee das ist so eine feine bled
richard e und zwar setzt dir dafür in
der unteren kann also in der kanne
einfach wasser auf bringt sie zum kochen
und oben habt ihr diese porzellan kann
und die porzellan kann sorgt auch dafür
dass der tee sein volles aroma entfalten
kann das bedeutet da gibt hier einfach
zwei esslöffeln vom tee hinein und dann
wird das ganze erstmal unter wasser
abgespült so ist einfach dass staub weg
und der schmutz weg und dann könnt ihr
das kalte wasser abgießen und dann
bringt er den tee eben mit dem heißen
wasser auf verschließt den deckel und
dann kommt das ganze auf die teekanne
und jetzt habt ihr oben ein t konzentrat
und unten das heiße wasser aus die ganze
zeit köchelt dann habe es immer so auf
stufe 1 bis 2 und dann kann man sich
eben den tee individuell zusammenstellen
so wie man ihn haben möchte manche
trinken stärker andere ein bisschen
weniger stark und es erkennt man dann
eben an der farbe aber das zeige ich
euch gleich so viel nur dazu weil da
etwa schon so 10 15 minuten durchziehen
muss ok dann zum türkischen frühstück
ich hatte auch schon mal ein video
stürme gemacht aber das war ein bisschen
anders gehört für mich auf jeden fall
gehören tomaten und spitz paprika da
kommt jetzt noch bears penis also
weichkäse dazu und da kam häufig jetzt
auch in letzter zeit die frage warum es
da verschiedene gibt und zwar ist der
grüne hier der 60 prozentige unser
lieblings käse weil der einfach den
höchsten fettgehalt hat und er schmeckt
halt deswegen cremig und lecker ihr
könnt aber auch den hellblauen nehmen
und die anderen farben diese neue lecker
aber man weiß ja je mehr fett umso
leckerer es war so ein geschmacksträger
und gibt die konsistenz das ist unser
liebster
[Musik]
dann auf jeden fall schwarze oliven und
wir nehmen da am liebsten diese kalamata
oliven das sind diese länglichen die
haben auch ordentlich fleisch dran das
ist ein richtig guter verlege ich sie
noch ein bisschen mit olivenöl und
zitrone manchmal rosmarin und orangen
und es würde man das gerne mag aber so
mit zitrone sind richtig gut
dann darf auf keinen fall fehlen tag hin
und weg dahin ist
sesampaste und pack ma's eben trauben
melasse und dann könnt ihr das einfach
zusammen so vermischen
[Musik]
was wir total gerne essen ist dieser
tomaten käse
der ist auch richtig gut
[Musik]
und was definitiv zum türkischen
frühstück dazu gehört ist kaymak nämlich
beim abbau ist honig und dann immer oft
sonne waren honig und kaymak das ist so
eine art rahmen die ist echt gut und in
der türkei es schmeckt es einfach so gut
aber hier hat man echt also wir holen
dann meist den von gabi und kein mag ist
schon ist schon was genial dass ich es
ist auch ganz gerne zu yamaha also zu
dieser mandl passte zu honig und man
kann zum bis im vergleich mit mascarpone
oder süßen rahmen aber die konsistenz
aber der hammer
[Musik]
frühstück ist fertig du darfst kommen
kawakawa deutsches frühstück da fehlt
jetzt noch nur spiegelei filme und ein
alles ist perfekt das ist für mich ist
spa und sesamkringel so ist auf ihren ja
warum
der test galt der monatswerte zerstörung
meine güte gemeinsam geschaut sondern
aufnahmen
sie sich jetzt so ein typisches
bauernfrühstück mit
könnte das rad ein frischer anstrich ist
das als richtig cool er müsse aufpassen
ob die scharf sind oder nicht schaffst
du meine erkenntnis außen oftmals gar
nicht ob sie aber oft sind die dunklen
einfach die schärfe
und das sind jetzt oft
profession stück von den lecker und zwar
mit bekommst du wirklich der türkei das
ist so wie die deutsche presse überall
also natürlich gibt es keine grenzen der
gips sie mit und wie kannst du an jeder
straßenecke kaufen und ich finde es
schade dass es in deutschland noch nicht
so richtig druck gesetzt haben pensionen
usern auch die atacama probieren und
ruhig zwischen und jetzt gibt es
vereinzelt aber so richtig krass
durchgesetzt wie
die türkische presse
da wird es auch um die
bilder machen hast du also dazu müssen
die zuschauer was das ist hier ja der
ist richtig genial imkerei marken honig
hammermäßig chance beheimaten honig
einfach verrühren oder hier noch bis
sonntag in prag gesagt du nicht rein
weil du warst du ich hab schon
eingedeckt
also sie machen jetzt die fotos und dann
kann ich rein kippen und machen und das
kann man das macht mich richtig an ich
weiß dass das zum teil in pöttmes wir
sind so sachen ja das ist in deutschland
untersuchen bekannt ist
man muss oder sesam
sesampaste und trauben mir lassen und
gar
nicht
mehr braucht man eigentlich auch gar
nicht und wenn dieses image also wenn
ihr noch welche übrig habt am nächsten
oder übernächsten tag war es mal ganz
gut auch machen kann ihr könnt entweder
im ofen erwerben oder einfach auf seinem
grill mit so einem toaster so kontakte
richtig gut genau aufsteigen wurst und
käse rein aber oder einfach ohne füllung
genau und dann habe das ja auch wieder
richtig frisch und ich finds auch für
die kinder gut zum mitnehmen oder fürs
büro zur arbeit hervorragend probiert
gerne mal aussehen aber wir sehen wir
machen ein bisschen sauberer und bis
jemand ist halt auch mit terror und im
sitzen ich möchte aber cool der piccolo
dann ist das überblick ich fänds auge
des fans august also eine challenger
alle bäckereien nimmt doch cell
sesamkringel mit mit in ihr angebot auf
oder die fans auch super oder schade ist
es nicht beim einkaufen im hintergrund
der gefriert das ist ausstellung zum
aufbacken michael ja das ist ich finde
es vor lachen das wenn man hier in
geschäfte ein kurs larry cohen wenn ihr
auf die idee kommen sollte absolut mit
absolute marktlücke dieses limits zum
aufbacken zum ersten mal nicht jeder hat
einen türken um die ecke
wir haben die tür im haus
[Gelächter]
macht gut deshalb gibt es wie immer in
meiner app oder auf meinem blog ich
wünsche euch viel spaß dabei und ihr
könnt ja gern mal schreiben ob ihr
ziemlich schon mal gegessen habt oder
nicht oder sogar selbst gebacken habe
also ich heute dass er stimmen halo ist
supergut das freut mich dann viel spaß
beim namen machen bis zum nächsten mal
dann trage ich das jetzt raus und ich
habe auch frischen tee gemacht und ein
glas sekt